Hello Freak bitches.
So you don't think there should be any minimum wage at all?
No,
no,
no.
None boat.
So someone working for a dollar an hour,
it doesn't bother you.
Well,
I mean it's better than working for zero.
I mean,
people think that,
um,
you know,
they,
they want to impose their morals and say,
well,
it's not right for somebody to work for a dollar an hour.
Well,
you know,
people make rational decisions,
right?
And so if somebody is accepting a dollar an hour,
and that must mean that nobody offered them a dollar 50,
nobody offered them $2.
I mean,
this is a competitive market.
I know you have an employee over here.
I mean,
could you pay this guy a dollar an hour?
Would you work for you?
I don't think so.
Yeah.
What gets me up because he could get more.
Right.
But he's,
he's educated and skilled and he's an engineer and of course,
right.
But it's very difficult for people to get that sort of an education,
particularly in Puerto Rico,
thought it was a third world environment.
So country,
it's not third world.
But let's say some kid came in here that had no experience whatsoever,
but he wanted to learn.
He wanted to just get you coffee and just sit around and be around you.
He's not that productive.
Yeah,
they use interns,
right?
A lot of radio stations do that and they don't pay them anything.
I know that $0 million and I can't do that.
Well then yeah,
but maybe you pay him $5 now,
whatever it is,
but people,
people are going to accept a job.
That's the best one they can get,
and so if somebody is working for a dollar an hour or $2 an hour,
by default,
I know that they couldn't find a higher job than that because,
and the reason is because they don't have a lot of skills.
But if you don't have a lot of skills,
the best thing you can do is get a job so you can get some skills.
That's where you learn skills,
you get more skills.
You know,
there are people that pay to get skills,
right?
If you go to school,
you actually have to pay tuition.
If I'm getting paid a dollar an hour while I learned something that has value,
that's better.
You have people now borrowing money to learn a skill.
People Graduate College and they're in debt.
That's a weird argument,
right?
Because you're assuming that they're going to get a skill.
I mean,
they might just be handling packages and picking them up and moving to another
location.
Even that's a whole or well,
even that's like show up on time,
be responsible,
so disciplines and showed a lot of work.
There's a lot of stuff that you learn when you have a job,
but the problem with the minimum wage is that the minimum wage basically hurts
the very people that it's intended to help because the minimum wage basically
says if you are a worker,
if you cannot convince an employer to pay you seven 25 or $10 an hour,
whatever the minimum is,
then you cannot accept that job.
See,
it doesn't hurt the employer.
It hurts the employee because it limits his options.
It limits his ability to sell his Labor for the highest price that he can get,
and it limits his access to the job market.
It's a,
you know,
you can't get on that ladder.
You,
you know,
you remove the lower rungs.
And so I can't climb up because of this arbitrary minimum wage because when you
pass a minimum wage,
you're not going to force an employer,
right?
If I'm an employer and there's a minimum wage of $10 an hour and somebody comes
to me and they can deliver $5 an hour worth of productivity,
meaning if I hire that person that will benefit me by $5 an hour,
I'm not going to pay them $10 an hour because then I lose $5 an hour.
The only way I'm going to hire somebody who's going to give me $5 an hour worth
of productivity is if I can buy them.
If I can hire him for less than $5 an hour so I can make a profit.
So it just,
it just a floor.
It's like if you cannot deliver enough productivity of whatever that minimum
wages,
then you can't get a job.
And so it's basically making it illegal for people to work.
It is the stupidest law that anybody has ever conceived.
A,
it should be obliterated.
I mean,
there are some countries like Singapore does not have a minimum wage and you
know,
the average income in Singapore is higher than it is here per capita.
There's a lot more millionaires there.
I mean,
people have no problem.
We didn't always have a minimum wage in the United States.
I mean,
this is a creation of government and you know,
but the,
the initial minimum wages,
if you want to actually go to the origins of minimum wage in the United States,
it was about trying to prevent employers from hiring the Chinese or hiring
blacks.
They were trying to force them in ways as a way to create unemployment.
It wasn't,
there wasn't a a good motivation.
But yes,
when they try to sell it to the voters,
oh,
it was all about,
we don't want people to be exploited,
but you know,
it's not exploitation.
If people voluntarily accept the job because it's the best job they can find,
the person who's offering the best job is not exploiting them.
They're giving them an opportunity.
And if you're denied an opportunity,
I mean there are a lot of people,
oh great,
you know they're going to get the minimum wage up to $15 an hour.
Well what good is it being unemployed at $15 an hour?
It's better to be employed at $5 an hour than unemployed at 15 because being
unemployed means you make nothing.
Right.
We're a devil's advocate would be that if you can't afford to pay someone $15 an
hour,
then you probably shouldn't have employees in the first place.
Your Business doesn't function that well.
No,
there are plenty.
because there are plenty of jobs where you have entry level positions.
I mean,
if you think that there should be no entry level jobs,
I mean you go back to the days of a full service gas stations right?
Back in the day when,
you know,
you didn't have to pump your own gas to the case in New Jersey and a few other
states,
New Jersey,
you know,
they mandate it,
but you still don't get the level of service.
I mean,
if you've pulled into a gas station 40 years ago,
not only did they pump your gas,
but they checked under your hood.
They,
I used to do it.
Tires,
you're,
you know,
they,
they watched your windows.
Um,
you know,
they did all sorts of things.
Uh,
you know,
with,
with your car,
they didn't make very much money.
They lived off of tips.
By and large,
it was the minimum wage that eliminated almost all those jobs.
It's a minimum wage.
That is the reason that we have,
you know,
people sell so much self serve.
But what happened,
a lot of these people,
these kids that worked in filling stations became mechanics because all these
filling stations had a mechanic there.
And,
and they,
they learned to auto mechanics and a lot of them went on to own their own gas
stations.
But of course a lot of them just,
this was their work experience that formed the basis for the rest of their life.
A lot of young kids had these jobs,
summer jobs,
and so there's nothing wrong with a entry level employment.
There's nothing wrong with people learning.
The responsibility of having a job of showing up of customer service of
salesmen.
My first jobs were all sales.
I was selling subscriptions door to door.
I was telephone sales as the z channel and California I sold,
I was knocking on doors selling cable television.
I worked in a shoe store selling shoes.
I mean,
but hustler.
But you were talking about you as a young man,
right?
A lot of people think of the minimum wage as applied to adults,
adults that have to take care of children,
that I have to put a roof over their head and food on the table.
And you're saying that that,
that they shouldn't be having those jobs.
Well,
by the time you are an adult with kids,
you should have accumulated the skills to earn a lot more than a minimum wage.
So that's the argument.
When people say,
Hey,
you can't afford a family.
You can't support a family on the minimum wage.
Of course,
you shouldn't even be trying to support a family.
If you can only earn the minimum wage,
you shouldn't have a family.
You,
you should realize,
hey,
I can't afford a family yet.
Let me acquire the skills before I start fathering children.
Right?
And getting married.
Let me make sure I can support myself.
I mean,
a lot of people who are having the minimum wage,
they're living at home,
they're there.
They,
you know,
they don't need to pay the rent.
They're living rent free.
What they need is a job they need maybe gas money,
get some money.
So I could take a girl out on a date,
but I gotta I got to get some work experience.
I got to get out there.
I got to know what it's like to work.
I got to see,
you know,
I've got to live in the real world and that's what used to happen.
I mean,
you don't have all these summer jobs anymore.
Kids don't have the opportunity because the minimum wage has already priced them
out.
A lot of older people now we're taking those,
those jobs.
And so the employment opportunities aren't there.
But when you just raise him in a wage,
all you're doing is raising the bar where you can get your job.
You're not helping people.
Now,
there's always going to be some people that,
yeah,
there's going to be somebody who will make a little bit more because of the
minimum wage.
There's going to be those people,
there's gonna be some winners,
but you're going to have lots of people that make nothing because of the minimum
wage.
And then of course,
because you're driving up the cost of labor prices are going up.
And so who is affected the most by higher prices?
Poor people.
People who are working on minimum wage.
Uh,
and not only that,
you end up with less quality.
I mean,
you know,
I hate it when I call up a company and I'm just in voice mail.
Hell.
And I'm going from when I would like a real person to deal with.
But you know the mood,
the minimum wage,
those jobs don't exist.
There's so many jobs that have been automated out of existence because not
automated shipped overseas where there isn't any minimum that too.
I mean that too.
Yeah.
You end up,
if you,
if you actually get a real person there in India,
right,
right.
But we have all these people in America who aren't working.
Why can't they do those jobs?
Yes.
You're not going to be able to support a family on those jobs.
But before you even get a family,
you can have that job and then maybe five or 10 years later,
you'll work your way up the ladder,
get a skill,
and then you can support a family.
But nobody is supposed to be able to support a family.
And if you try to tell an employer,
hey,
you got to,
you gotta Pay Your Fry,
Cook enough money to support a family.
You can't do that.
There's not enough productivity cooking French fries.
You can't support a family family.
If all you can do is cook a French fry,
you need to learn how to do something else before you can support a family and
you can't,
you can't put that on the employer.
Now when you say that Singapore has a higher average income is,
is that because and no minimum wage,
is that because there's a shitload of billionaires that have moved to Singapore
because they don't have a minimum wage because they can explore no lower class
people or people that don't make much money.
The the millionaires and billionaires don't eve are really not even affected by
the minimum wage.
What you'd have to look at is the rate of unemployment,
which is tiny in Singapore.
Yes.
They have sentence for very rich people to move there and doesn't that Jack up
the minimum wage or not the minimum wage or either the average income?
Yeah.
Well,
the fact that you have entrepreneurs that are succeeding in Singapore because
they have small government and low taxes means that there's a lot of competition
for workers and so that's what bids up wages,
right?
Competition.
I mean,
I've got no problem with a vibrant market bidding up wages.
You just don't want the government to try to artificially force wages above
their productivity.
Right.
Because it's ultimately your productivity that determines your wages.
Okay.